you can't just show up here with no  warning what's up did something happen  yes  nicholas has come to live with me and  he's improving but he's a little fragile  the way he came to see me you're blaming  me for what happened  he's different from the others what  makes you say that  why don't you answer me i do answer you  the look in his eye is disturbing she  wants to turn us against one another  [Music]  back then there's so much joy in our  family i feel like a complete failure if  i'm like this it's your fault what have  i done what's my fault haven't i always  done everything for you i have the right  to reinvent my life it is my life  everything okay at home  yeah  everything's fine  you